your insurance agency the sponsors of
this next segment have partnered with
health plan of nevada to help you during
this important time for older adults
take a look
[Music]
hello my name is chris carruthers and
i'm here at the meadows mall here in las
vegas at your insurance agency we're
here today to talk about open enrollment
which is the time of year when it's time
to consider switching health plans so
today our special guest with this is
rhonda czech with helpland nevada
welcome thank you chris
so open enrollment's not the same for
everybody if you're currently covered by
an employer plan normally open
enrollment happens between september and
december of every year if you're not
covered by an employer plan open
enrollment is happening now through
january 15th
so some important tips for you to
consider during open enrollment
is what is your family's needs what are
your medical needs so it's important to
sit down and have that continued
relationship with us as an agency and as
a broker to help you navigate those best
choices for you and your family
one thing to be considering is are you
going to get pregnant or is that
something you need to address or is
there pretending pending surgery so on
those are the things we need to help you
help you guide you to make that best
decision but also there's some changes
that have come with tax credits so these
are vitally important decisions for you
to navigate so please come in and and
work with us either in any of our mall
locations but also virtually
yes especially chris during covid it's
important to consider a plan that offers
virtual visits whether traveling
work
juggling kids re schedules or you just
simply enjoy seeing the doctor from the
convenience of your own home it's
important to consider health plan of
nevada with their virtual visits 24 7.
understand how the prescription drug
benefits work
are your current drugs covered do they
offer low-cost alternatives such as
generic drugs
mental health mental health is very
important to your health and overall
well-being not only do you get in-person
service with health plan in nevada we
offer virtual visits for mental health
services and don't forget specialty
benefits dental vision hearing life
disability they're all very important to
your overall health health plan nevada
does have great resources for our
community our clients have benefited
with them over the years and we really
appreciate those virtual visits
especially during this covet season
so don't forget open enrollment is
ending december 15th however that's for
a january first start date and this
year's special because they are
extending it to january 15th but then
your benefits will start february 1st so
please make a decision early so you
don't have a gap in coverage
don't forget that we are certified with
nevada health link and we have expert
brokers here to help you navigate the
choices that are best for you and your
family and we're here to help and happy
to serve you
thank you to your insurance agency for
sponsoring this segment call
702-425-5500 or visit y i a
nv.com to consult your local broker
before december 15th